hello and welcome back to omics logic
data science in this program we discuss
methods for analysis of big data and
data wrangling these are essential
skills for bioinformaticians as well as
those interested in other types of
non-biology related research using
various methods of data analysis so what
we do in this program is we want to try
to understand how to work with different
types of omics data performing
exploratory analysis and the steps to
process big data and prepare it for
downstream analysis steps
then try some of the big data analysis
tools for large-scale project data and
apply different types of machine
learning techniques and learn about the
important links between
biological data and the actual biology
that it represents to master biological
interpretation
so in the first part of the program we
focused on some of these introductory
steps how to work with different types
of omics data like genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and others
we saw some of the challenges associated
with preparing that big data for
analysis
and we did an overview of different
methods to handle and structure
preparing the data for visualization and
in-depth analysis and so in the second
part of the program we are now focusing
on a variety of different methods
including univariate and multivariate
analysis methods as well as examples of
how to apply machine learning and
artificial intelligence to the workflows
that we would like to perform with such
data so in today's session we will
continue to speak about unsupervised
learning methods and that includes
dimensionality reduction and clustering
so specifically we will discuss how
several different approaches to
clustering such as k-means hierarchical
clustering and different types of
spectral clustering called db scan can
be applied to different types of data
into different types of questions and we
will also talk about how to practically
apply them using the t-bindfold platform
as well as using r and python and so
then we will speak about some of the
challenges for various methods and when
to apply which algorithm how to validate
your findings how to use these
techniques and how to combine them
together to achieve your analysis
objectives so a lot of interesting
topics that we want to cover today let's
get started
so before we jump into the topic of
today's session let's do a little review
kind of remember where we are in the
program what we have covered so far and
where are we going why are we performing
these steps of clustering and
dimensionality reduction so so far you
should have learned about preparing the
data for analysis exploring it and
linking patterns that have been found
with biological interpretation what does
it mean and how to get an intuition
about what you are expecting to find
to do that in the first part we
discussed a lot of the analytical
pipelines they can load in the raw
sequencing data and prepare a table of
elements that could be analyzed with the
different methods that we discussed so
these pipelines vary by the type so here
for example you see a pipeline for
transcriptomic data analysis or here you
see a pipeline for metagenomic data
analysis the pipelines are different but
they utilize some of the same principles
and the principles are pre-processing or
clearing up some of the noise from the
raw sequences mapping how do we actually
align it to some reference either genome
or a whole maybe database of elements
and then how do we compare different
conditions by quantifying how much of
different types of elements do we
actually have and that can be a table of
expression where we quantify mrna for
genes mutations
or maybe operational taxonomic units so
how do we actually get
those taxonomic units and how do we
interpret that data for example in the
case of genomic data analysis we can
obtain the table of somatic scores per
sample across all of the genomic
positions in the dna of the reference
organism high somatic scores correspond
to frequently observed mutations in
sequencing reads and we interpret them
to mean that these are mutations that
were acquired as a result of cell
division that's why they're called
somatic mutations
for example we can talk about
transcriptomic data we have a table of
continuous numeric data for gene isoform
or exon expression levels annotated by
gene id and organized consistently
across samples in a given experiment so
in this table you have
samples as columns gene ids as rows and
the intersection is the level of
expression of that gene for that sample
in the case of metagenomic data we look
at operational taxonomic unit so 16s
ribosomal rna amplicon which means that
these are only regions that are
amplified metagenomic sequencing data we
have a table of otus or operational
taxonomic units also across samples with
proportionate abundance in each
microbial community so together with
this table what we need is the
annotation of the taxonomy of these
operational taxonomic units to interpret
the composition of the microbiome sample
so to explore these tables we also learn
how to visualize different properties of
the data and summarize them using the
statistical properties that can help us
explore the major signal and variation
across samples
we also learned to use different
statistical approaches or analysis
techniques that help us find specific
patterns of interest such as for example
differentially expressed genes between
groups of samples
the statistical methods that we talk
about are
used widely today to find patterns that
are sort of easy to interpret
biologically so for example hypothesis
testing for each gene that represents
genes that are consistently and strongly
different between conditions so
differential gene expression analysis is
commonly understood to represent a
biologically meaningful way to identify
key genes that could be interpreted and
validated and so finally we spoke about
some of the major challenges because of
data variability and how the steps to
explore data are very important to
differentiate between signal and noise
specifically in the statistical
approaches we often times look for the
most significant patterns and then we
also have this challenge of minor
patterns that could actually describe
data that covers many different
conditions across a lot of variability
and in noisy data and that is when we
turn to machine learning and so machine
learning methods can be separated into
two main categories of methods
unsupervised machine learning that
focuses on detection
of patterns in data and the second main
category is the supervised machine
learning methods and these methods rely
on availability of training data so data
that has been labeled once a data set of
labeled data is accumulated it can be
used to train a model that will be able
to apply this knowledge to analyze new
data for example by predicting a class
so with unsupervised machine learning
methods we start with a data set
typically it's a table of elements just
like what we saw and here we can use
shapes as examples so we can use a
clustering method for example
hierarchical clustering or k-means
clustering and these could identify
groups in the data and the fact that it
places each sample into a group
based on some feature in this case shape
is the learning process and so the
outcome of the learning method is
identification and assignment of each
sample to a group which means that each
group has a boundary and we can study
each group separately
one unsupervised machine learning method
that we already talked about is
principal component analysis let's
imagine some kind of a data set that
looks like a cloud we can find a
particular type of a projection for
example we can take two of the first
features that can either show us low
variance or high variance now in either
case
maybe the features that we have in our
data don't represent the full data in a
very accurate way so what we can do is
we can have a projection
based on principal components that are
projected in this original data that
maximize variance or explain variance of
the original dataset
principle component analysis uses
explained variance to show us the most
accurate way to represent our data but
it is not always going to work well for
any kind of data in metagenomic
sequencing data we're interested to
understand how diversity changes across
samples and can be used to understand
composition which can be done using
non-metric multi-dimensional scaling or
nmds the goal of an mds is to collapse
information from multiple communities
sites etc into just a few so that they
can be visualized and compared unlike
other ordination techniques that rely on
primarily euclidean distances such as
principal coordinates analysis nmds uses
rank orders and thus it is an extremely
flexible technique that can accommodate
a variety of different kinds of data
another method that seeks to deal with
various assumptions about data
distribution and complex structure is t
sne or t sne which stands for t
distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding it uses connectivity to
establish neighborhoods and data and
then shows a lower dimension
representation of the connectedness
between data points using a projection
mapping that seeks to accurately
represent the original topology in our
data set perplexity is what t-sne would
use to represent the distance between
samples which is a measure for
information that is defined as 2 to the
power of the shannon entropy in t sne
the perplexity may be viewed as a knob
that sets the number of effective
nearest neighbors it is comparable with
the number of nearest neighbors k that
is employed in many manifold learners so
what we will do today is we will
continue our discussion about machine
learning and we will turn to clustering
cluster analysis or clustering is the
task of grouping a set of objects in
such a way that objects in the same
group are more similar to each other
than to those in other groups
importantly this approach tends to be
deterministic it seeks to determine for
each point which group to assign it to
while this is not the case for all
methods some determine belonging to a
group based on initiation which can lead
to different interpretations each run
this is the main difference between
simply representing the data in the
lower dimension and assigning an actual
cluster to each point
and this is specifically helpful when
some overlap between point groups make
it difficult to accurately determine
belonging to a group and provides a
rationale to study cluster points as a
part of a single unit so to explain
let's take a look at our data here we
have known groups that are clinical
subtypes of breast cancer each gene has
a profile so for example this is a
profile
of this particular gene this is a small
example so we only have 15 genes but if
we plot a bar plot for each gene we
start seeing some patterns and they show
some similarity between samples of the
same type some logic behind similarity
can now be determined by automatically
assigning each sample into a defined
group so that it belongs to just one
cluster using all of the gene expression
values so here we can see the patterns
but how do we use all of this data
together and actually come up with all
of the patterns determining the same
thing or belonging of samples to a
particular group there are many
different types of clustering and they
are defined by different clustering
algorithms they use several different
approaches so let's take a look at some
of these the partitioning algorithms
divide data objects into a number of
partitions where each partition
represents a cluster these clusters
should fulfill the following requirement
one each group must contain at least one
object and two each object must belong
to exactly one group for example we have
the k-means algorithm where the center
is the average of all points and
coordinates represent the arithmetic
mean there are many other partitioning
algorithms such as k modes pam clara
clarons and fcm the second example is
the hierarchical based where data is
organized in a hierarchical manner
depending on the medium of proximity
proximities are obtained by the
intermediate nodes a dendrogram
represents the data sets where
individual data is represented by leaf
nodes the initial cluster gradually
divides into several clusters as the
hierarchy continues hierarchical
clustering methods can be agglomerative
or bottom-up and divisive or top-down an
agglomerative clustering starts with one
object for each cluster and recursively
merges two or more of the most
appropriate clusters a divisive cluster
starts with the dataset as one cluster
and recursively splits the most
appropriate cluster the process
continues until a stopping criterion is
reached frequently the requested number
k of clusters the hierarchical method
has a major drawback though which
relates to the fact that once a step
merge or split is performed it cannot be
undone some examples for hierarchical
clustering include birch cure rock and
chameleon density based here data
objects are separated based on their
regions of density connectivity and
boundary they are closely related to the
point nearest neighbors a cluster
defined as a connected dense component
grows in any direction that density
leads to therefore density based
algorithms are capable of discovering
clusters of arbitrary shapes and also
this provides a natural protection
against outliers so the overall density
of a point is analyzed to determine the
functions of a data set that influence a
particular data point dbscan optics db
clast and then clue are algorithms that
use such a method to filter out noise
which are outlier and discover clusters
of arbitrary shapes another approach is
grid based where the space of the data
objects is divided into grids the main
advantage of this approach is that it
has fast processing time because it goes
through the data set once to compute the
statistical values of the grid the
accumulated grid data make grid-based
clustering techniques independent of the
number of data objects that employ a
uniform grid to collect regional
statistical data and then perform the
clustering on the grid instead of the
database directly the performance of a
grid-based method depends on the size of
the grid which is usually much less than
the size of the actual data set however
for highly regular data distributions
using a single uniform grid may not be
sufficient to obtain the required
clustering quality or fulfill the time
requirement some example methods include
wave cluster and sting that belong to
this category so finally we have the
model based approaches these are methods
that optimize the fit between the given
data and some predefined mathematical
model this is based on the assumption
that the data is generated by a mixture
of underlying probability distributions
and also it leads to a way of
automatically determining the number of
clusters based on standard statistics
taking noise which are the outliers into
account and thus yielding a robust
clustering method there are two major
approaches that are based on the model
based method statistical and neural
network approaches mklust is probably
the best known model based algorithm but
there are other good algorithms such as
em expectation maximization which uses a
mixture density model conceptual
clustering such as cobweb and neural
network approaches such as
self-organizing feature maps so let's
take a look at several examples for the
first three types of clustering methods
that we described so far
hierarchical clustering is one of the
most popular approaches because it
allows clustering on different levels
even though we typically choose and have
to specify the number of expected
clusters k the way this algorithm works
does not actually require the k but only
is needed at the end once the hierarchy
of data points is established to see how
let's demonstrate how this method works
so let's say we have our samples
organized in some space so imagine a pca
plot like this one 2d plot where each
sample is positioned in some perspective
that best represents the date of
variance the way the algorithm works is
it finds points in this space that are
the closest to each other and assigns
the center
for those two points as a pseudo cluster
we perform the same operation to find
the nearest
neighbor
and organize them together and so when
we connect those two points that's
called linkage and we use different
methods of measuring distance between
points to establish the link and
ultimately the algorithm will stop once
we reach all of the samples belonging to
the same cluster so this was an example
of bottom-up agglomerative clustering
let's see how this algorithm actually
work so here we have our points
distributed in this two-dimensional
space you can see that the nearest
points are organized as a single point
and once all of the points reach the
same cluster
now we know that we have built the full
hierarchy now based on this hierarchy we
can determine some kind of a threshold
where we cut off this hierarchical tree
and determine the number of samples in
each cluster to run clustering on the
tbinfo platform you will need to upload
the table of expression that we
generated when we analyze for example
our cell line data this data can be
downloaded directly from the lesson or
from a demo pipeline in the cell line
rna-seq demo clustering methods are
located under the data mining section of
the platform
hierarchical clustering is an example of
agglomerative or bottom-up clustering
method that starts with attributing each
sample to a separate cluster it then
finds the pair of the most similar
samples and unites them in one cluster
that is further distributed as one
quasi-sample this procedure is repeated
until coming to one cluster that
contains all of the samples so when we
put the data into the pipeline it will
load the data perform clustering and put
out the result in several different
formats that we will discuss in a little
bit so what are the parameters that we
have to choose first of all we have to
choose the right linkage which is a
parameter determines the definition for
measuring inter-cluster distance single
sets the definition as the distance
between the two nearest points in two
clusters whereas complete defines the
distance as that between the two
farthest points the two ward methods are
variation of ward's minimum variance
betting
the distance parameter is the second one
which specifies the distance metric to
use in measuring distance between data
points and this could be euclidean
manhattan maximum or canberra and then
we have the cluster's expected count
which is a parameter that sets the
cut-off height
of the hierarchical dendrogram to the
one that results in a given number of
clusters and then we have the option to
transpose our data which is a parameter
that allows us to transpose the table
and either analyze genes or analyze
samples so what is cluster linkage so
there are several different types we
talked about right and we talked about
the average linkage and this is the
method that finds all possible pairwise
distances for points belonging to two
different clusters and then calculates
the average this method is less affected
by outliers than the other ones
single linkage which uses the minimum
difference to determine clustering the
distance between two groups is defined
as the distance between their two
closest members and we have other types
like centroid and complete linkage then
we have different parameters for
distance and understanding the choice
between all of these different methods
really is based on your understanding of
the input data so the hierarchical
clustering algorithm is a process by
which a computer uses the input file
where columns or objects and rows are
features
then it assigns each object to separate
cluster or group and then it evaluates
all pairwise distances between clusters
using a chosen distance metric and
constructs a distance matrix
using the distance values then it finds
the pair of clusters with the shortest
distance and merges them into a single
cluster and then it repeats these steps
until we end up with a single cluster
for all of the samples and as a result
what do we get we get the hierarchy of
our samples
organized into a dendrogram here we have
an example of a dendrogram and you can
see that we can cut it off at different
points to get the desired number of
clusters at the very top we have two
clusters then we have four clusters then
we have eight clusters another method
that we will talk about is k-means which
is probably the most popular clustering
algorithm of all it is a partition type
of an approach the algorithm itself is
relatively simple starting with a
pre-specified number of cluster centers
each point is initially assigned to its
nearest center
in the next step for each segment the
centers are moved to the centroid of the
clustered points the points are then
reassigned to their nearest center the
process is repeated until moving the
centers derives little or no improvement
which is measured by the within cluster
sum of squares which is the total
squared distance between each point
and its clustered center
in the k-means pipeline we also input a
table of expression in a txt file and
after running the algorithm we're able
to observe three different things first
the k-means clustering does not do a
great job of clustering for a lot of
these examples because of the many
different features that we have
essentially thousands of features per
sample so if we compare the two methods
k means and the hierarchical clustering
we will see that they produce different
results so essentially because of the
metrics that we select we expect to find
the same number of clusters for example
four but depending on the metric that we
use we can see those clusters separating
and we can always evaluate the results
based on what we know about the samples
for example we know which sample belongs
to which clinical phenotype
now another type of clustering is
spectral clustering spectral clustering
techniques make use of the spectrum or
the eigenvalues of the similarity matrix
of the data to perform dimensionality
reduction before clustering in fewer
dimensions
the similarity matrix is provided as an
input and consists of a quantitative
assessment of the relative similarity of
each pair of points in the data set the
basic algorithm consists of several
steps that are based on the laplacian
matrix which is a way to represent a
graph of interconnected nodes and study
graph relationships the same approach is
used for non-linear embedding or
dimensionality reduction techniques like
umap
spectral clustering does not work well
on all data because it is
computationally expensive unless the
graph is sparse and the similarity
matrix can be efficiently constructed a
special case of spectral clustering is
called db scan which stands for density
based spatial clustering of applications
with noise
so now that we reviewed the methods and
some of the ways that we can run them
let's discuss when such methods can be
used and how to interpret the results or
analyze their outputs in a meaningful
way
for example we can compare how different
clustering and dimensionality reduction
technique can provide us with insights
about data so if we label our data based
on known labels like here we have
different types of breast cancer
subtypes we can see how the major
structure of data is separated into two
big groups and we can see in our pca
scatter plot that we essentially get the
same thing right everything is separated
between luminal and all the rest
so the most obvious way to use the
threshold is to set the threshold to
divide everything into two major types
the distance between them is determined
by the height and you can see that the
distance in both our pca plot and the
cluster dendrogram could be
comparable a good way to test clustering
models is to also compare phenotype data
with the unsupervised classification we
created so in this case we see here a
smaller number of genes that was used
and as a result we can also determine
the most far
separated groups that we have the same
thing goes for pca
where we can see a separation between
the luminal group and
the non-malignant group right here
oftentimes clustering can also help us
find outliers for example here
we can see an irregular tree that
highlights the sample hgc202
and then if we want to actually check
whether this makes some kind of a sense
we can see that actually this specific
cell line htc 202 has been
studied and found not to belong to the
same category of cell lines that we
typically think it should be assigned to
clustering is also widely used in data
visualization because it helps us
organize visual patterns into heat maps
for example so we visually determine
groups of samples and genes and a lot of
times this is going to be useful when we
perform differential gene expression and
we want to demonstrate how
differentially expressed genes actually
are organized into two different groups
of samples like we see here on the right
or on the left we can also identify
specific common genes that are organized
in some kind of a form between groups of
samples
another way to use clustering is also to
find correlated expression of genes
across samples that can reveal
meaningful biological function that is
shared between groups of genes and
affected in similar ways through
perturbation so when we have different
conditions
we expect those conditions to affect
biological function so if we take our
data set and we separate it here in four
clusters and then we visualize
what are those patterns for each cluster
we can see that they are correlated now
if we find a group that is highly
correlated and different from other
patterns in the data we can then assume
perhaps they somehow are linked to each
other and maybe they form a biological
function so going through annotation as
you can see here on the bottom right can
help us understand what could be that
function okay so now that we reviewed
the methods and we understand how to run
them let's discuss how clustering
methods can be compared evaluated and
selected for a specific objective or job
one simple way to understand how well
your clustering works is to try to plot
a confusion matrix between known classes
if they are available and the cluster
assignment in this way you can see which
sample is not being assigned to the
proper category if the annotation is not
available the confusion matrix can be
used to see if the same sample is being
assigned to an inappropriate cluster or
to several different clusters and that
will result in maybe changing the
settings or maybe iterative runs of the
same algorithm
in some cases your challenge would be to
determine how many clusters to expect in
that case you can use metrics like
inertia for k-means or silhouette for a
variety of different methods inertia
measures how well a data set was
clustered by k means it is calculated by
measuring the distance between each data
point and its centroid squaring the
distance and summing these squares
across one cluster a good model is one
with low inertia and a low number of
clusters in addition to the confusion
matrix a hierarchical clustering method
can show a dendrogram of linkages
between samples which can be
interpretable and can improve your
understanding of data this can be done
visually or with a metric score like the
silhouette score
the silhouette score is a method that is
common for many types of clustering
methods the average silhouette method
computes the average
of observations for different values of
k the optimal number of clusters k is
the one that maximizes the average
silhouette over a range of possible
values for k
the silhouette coefficient is calculated
using the mean intracluster distance and
the mean nearest cluster distance for
each sample thus you can choose k
and iteratively calculate the score to
maximize nearest cluster distance the
silhouette ranges from minus one to plus
one where a high value indicates that
the object is well matched to its own
cluster and poorly matched to
neighboring clusters if most objects
have a high value then the clustering
configuration is appropriate if many
points have a low or negative value then
the clustering configuration may have
too many or too few clusters
the gap statistic is an approach that
can be applied to any clustering method
to evaluate how well we have assigned
the number k
so what it does is it compares the total
with intracluster variation for
different values of k with their
expected values under no reference
distribution of the data the estimate of
the optimal clusters will be value that
maximizes the gap statistic
which yields the largest gap statistic
so this means that the clustering
structure is far away from the random
uniform distribution of points which
means that you have chosen the correct
number of k
in many cases a visual representation of
data can help significantly to
understand why a certain group is
determined to be a cluster or why an
outlier can reduce the quality of
clustering combining your analysis with
a representation of data can be a great
way to mine it for patterns and discover
ways to optimize the results of your
analysis
a completely different challenge can be
when you are trying to apply the same
approach
to feature similarity analysis so for
example we want to understand not the
clustering of samples like we see here
but we also want to try to understand
what groups are formed by different
features of our data set
one way to do this is to understand the
loading of features or how features
contribute to separation between groups
of samples in that case we can identify
the top features and those features can
have a direction in the same space that
separates the clusters that we have
but when we want to look at the actual
clusters in our data we can assume that
biological differences between groups of
samples represent some kind of an
influence and we can study how that
influence affects different genes which
as we will see in a few minutes reflects
the differences between samples and can
be useful for biological interpretation
now let's discuss
how to run
and understand the coding practices
behind some of these methods
on the t bioinfo platform you are
running methods implemented in r
for example when running the k-means
pipeline you will notice the output file
called rpac.zip
inside the zip file you will find the
source code designed to take in the
parameters from the platform and
translate those into variables used in
the main call of the clustering method
to understand the code and how to get
more from each method we provide a
number of tutorials in the course
introduction to data science in r the
first place where you encounter
clustering is in the pca lesson
there you will find advanced
implementation of pca visualization with
clustering methods clara pam and fanning
the methods are well suited for high
dimensional data that is reduced using
pca and scale
clara stands for clustering large
applications which is a method that
works on large data sets as compared to
k means or k meteoroids
and it will select random observations
from the data set and perform the
partitioning a similar method called pam
stands for partitioning around
meteorites using the library ggfordify
you will learn to perform pca and then
utilize the stats package to cluster the
pca objects and produce cluster results
in a visual format using ggplot2
autoplot function
in r there are at least several packages
that implement clustering algorithms in
a user-friendly fashion one of these is
the stats package that covers many
analysis tools for statistical analysis
and clustering age clust is dedicated to
hierarchical clustering using the
agglomerative bottom-up approach with
linkage and distance settings in the
usage call the same package implements
k-means
and other partition methods in r that
are called in a very similar way to each
other and are covered in the online
tutorials
to practice you will find examples in
the clustering lesson this will include
running the analysis and visualizing
results with a dendrogram you can
additionally explore interactive
dendrogram options that can be used for
coloring your dendrogram and finding the
right number of clusters to select
additional packages in r that you can
consider are packages cluster and pv
clust
cluster is a package that implements
hierarchical clustering with additional
features like the agglomerative
coefficient and other useful
visualization tools
another package pv quest adds a p-value
for hierarchical clustering using
bootstrap resembling in python
scikit-learn contains a number of
methods for clustering data and
evaluation of clustering performance on
the learn portal you will find tutorials
to practice syntax but also coding
challenges and a link to an interactive
notebook where multiple methods of
clustering are compared
the given assignment after clustering
methods illustrate how to apply the same
logic to clustering genes instead of
samples
as a result the additional notebook
offered in the lesson explains the
benefits of density-based clustering
methods like dbscan to identify closely
related genes that might share some
biological function or can be used to
identify artifacts in data or noise
in the follow-up exercise you will see
how these methods can be used after
non-linear dimensionality reduction like
t-sne and u-map where the number of
clusters can be more meaningful but also
the practice includes dealing with
removing outliers and working on
thorough comparison of results from
similar but different methods of
clustering in conclusion what did we
learn in today's session
we reviewed unsupervised learning
techniques like dimensionality reduction
and clustering in detail these include
partition-based methods like k-means
hierarchical methods like age cluster
birch and density-based methods like tv
scan we also talked about the ways we
can use clustering to identify
differences between samples or genes and
find meaningful patterns
we also spoke about ways to overcome
challenges in clustering and make
interpretation a bit easier finally we
discussed the ways that we can combine
various methods of dimensionality
reduction and clustering to find
biologically meaningful patterns in
complex data and how to use these
methods on the t by info platform or
implement them in r and python
thank you for joining this session and i
hope to see you in our next session
dedicated to classification